bonjour avec des mots vous avez regardé
le documentaire du réalisateur pierre
barnérias hold up consacré à la crise de
la copie 19 et vous ironisé sur ce mot
de complotisme cette accusation souvent
fait à l'égard de ce reportage
oui parce que je pense que ce
documentaire ne mérite ni cet excès
d'honneur ni cet excès d'indignité ouest
selon la fameuse formule c'est à dire
que ça c'est je le prends je les regarde
et j'ai trouvé ça interminable beaucoup
trop long mais avec beaucoup de choses
très intéressantes et la thèse en
revanche finalistes que je ne je ne
partage pas qui est en gros pour résumer
ce virus fabriqués à l'institut pasteur
envoyer ensuite aux chinois aurait été
le prétexte pour permettre aux partisans
du gouvernement mondial bill gates
attali et c'est d'imposer aux
populations une crypto monnaie qui
permettrait vous savez de 2 depuis ce
que vous payez votre téléphone ou avec
d'autres choses de vous contrôler et de
contrôler tout ce que vous faites ce que
vous achetez
j'avoue que la thèse ne me convainc pas
en revanche dans les deux heures et
demie que dure ce reportage il y a
beaucoup de choses très intéressantes et
beaucoup de choses très pertinentes et
des choses que je savais et et d'autres
que je n'y aurais voyez donc je trouve
un peu rapide et un peu facile et très
douteux de voir toute la caste
médiatique politique
voyez lui tomber dessus en disant
complotistes et et pour avoir moi même
subi ce genre d'agressions avec ce mot
là je sais maintenant que quand toute la
caste politico-médiatique vous traite de
complotite ça veut dire que vous essayez
alors nous trompons parfois en
réussissant d'autrefois avoir ce cas
derrière le rideau
oui et donc le complotisme c'est devenu
l' arme de guerre des élites pour
défendre leur vérité leur pré carré
contre des gens qui essayent d'en savoir
plus même si je vous dis en l'occurrence
derrière des choses très justes sur rail
route sur voyez sûr sûr sûr toute la
gestion de cette pandémie coupe
mon vol en particulier celle du
gouvernement français la thèse ne me
convainc pas la thèse finale mais je
sais ce que c'est que le couple mot
complotisme oui mais enfin quand même
défendre la liberté d'expression
pourfendre ceux qui dénoncent le
complotisme ne permet pas dire n'importe
quoi
non bien sûr mais je je je vous dis je
ne j'essaye de comprendre pourquoi on le
traite de complotiste et je comprends
c'est à dire que le il n'y a plus de
débat intellectuel possible si on
interdit à l'autre d'avoir une part de
d'analystes si on lui voiliers et jeux
en plus c'est très intéressant parce que
qu'est ce que nous disent tous les tous
ceux qui tombent sur ce pauvre mettant
en scène en plus apparemment il est
plutôt tendance mystique
il a fait des reportages sur la vierge
on la sait c'est carrément un crime
contre l'humanité donc on en rajoute
évidemment donc qu'est ce qu'on nous dit
on nous dit il y à une vérité et il ne
faut pas la contester
et pourtant ce sont nos élites depuis 40
ans depuis les campus américains des
années 40 tous les progressistes qui
nous ont appris qu'il n'y avait pas de
vérité avec un grand v qui nous ont
expliqué à longueur de journée à
longueur de livres que la vérité était
relative qu'elle était le produit de nos
conditionnements sociaux ratio sexuelle
genre et comme on dit aujourd'hui et que
même la langue n'était pas neutre et
qu'il fallait les c'était une arme de
combat et qu'il fallait la retourner
qu'il fallait changer les mots la
grammaire et s'était rhabillé queue leu
leu la vérité n'existe pas et qu'elle
est floue qu'elle est liquide comme on
dit aujourd'hui comme la société liquide
et donc évidemment nous avons été bien
éduqué donc aujourd'hui nous retournons
cet argument contre c est lui qui trouve
ça scandaleux
en fait selon vous ce qu'ils dénoncent
le complotisme ont tout fait pour qu'on
y croit et c'est exactement ça et ont
tout fait pour qu'on justement pour
qu'on ne croit pas à la vérité
officielle même si parfois elle peut
être juste mais ils nous ont appris à
douter de tout en fonction justement
même de la plus évidente
l'histoire de france la patrie la
famille tout ce qui était ancré
profondément nous
et on nous a appris à douter tout est
maintenant ces mêmes élites qui ont sapé
les fondements de la société
traditionnelle avec ce doute
tracy piel nous disent ah bah non il
faut pas douter de ce qu'on dit c'est
pas possible
merci eric zemmour